i was reading these fun facts about you
and they were so fun
can we do fun facts yes all right
oh wow okay you ready yes
is it true that you turn up the heat in
your garage and do hot yoga
oh my god yeah you inspired me this
morning and i did it too but in my
bedroom because i live in new york and
there's no garage degraded
fun fact you grew up going to a colorado
ranch where you rode horses
shot guns all taught by your dad
are you a secret cowgirl yeah
your production company tea time is so
cool
because it's not just a production
company you also curate art
movies tv and books
yes i do what's on your watch list
right now small acts
which is amazing on amazon
um ma rainey's black bottom we love
the dolly parton documentary we love
uh mike the bee gees documentary
a lot of movies a lot of music
documentaries would it be okay
if we posted this list on our website
and like kick back to yours because i
have read some of your lists they're
amazing and i'm
i love curating and suggesting it's
totally my thing
so could we have a little absolutely oh
good
okay okay fun fact your grandmother is
tippy hedren
which yeah she is i have a picture of
myself
uh dressed as her for halloween today
is her 91st birthday
oh the biggest happy birthday to your
legendary grandmother
thank you and fun fact
she is like the most incredible
lover rescuer taking care of of big cats
yes yeah she does have a couple of them
at home
i love that picture of her where the
like one's coming through the window
like eating out of her like 50s kitchen
yeah the kitchen is still exactly the
same oh
we were commenting on how cool it was so
i'm glad to know that
did you or did you not used to make
reservations
at restaurants under the name george
clooney as to get the best table
no it wasn't even to get the best table
it was just to get a reservation
but i did not um and that you saw george
clooney and he was like
yeah yeah weirdly i was like
he ca he i had not met him obviously and
he was like i've heard about what you've
done i'm like oh my god
but he was cool with it